apenas 55 días después de tomar el
control el reinado de elon musky como
ceo de Twitter parece estar llegando a
un final prematuro el hombre de 51 años
anunció sus planes de renunciar como más
sino con un tuit renunciaré Cómo ha sido
tan pronto como encuentre alguien lo
suficientemente tonto como para aceptar
el puesto después de eso solo dirigiré
los equipos de software y servidores
el anuncio llega a menos de dos meses
después de la compra de la red social
por 44 mil millones de dólares y es
consecuencia de una encuesta que él
mismo lanzó el domingo planteó la
pregunta a sus más de 120 millones de
Seguidores debo renunciar además
prometió respetar lo que arrojara el
sondeo 24 horas y 17 millones de votos
después los resultados estaban listos
con el 57,5% de los votantes queriendo
que musky renuncie un capítulo que sólo
trae más inestabilidad para el sitio de
redes sociales Twitter a Estados Unidos
en un caos financiero y administrativo
desde la llegada de elon musk la mitad
del personal despedido restauración de
cuentas suspendidas búsqueda de
inversores sin éxito Twitter está en
crisis y ha tenido repercusiones en las
otras empresas del considerado hombre
más rico del mundo incluyendo tesla en
tres meses el valor de las acciones del
fabricante de automóviles eléctricos se
ha reducido en más de la mitad